for the past 15 years in the month of
December 20 to 30 people sit across the
table from me and we go through their
business plan what they did that year
good bad ugly and what they're planning
on doing the following urine and I give
some feedback on mindset and things they
need to be working on today it's not
about the twenty or thirty people today
it's about you and I it's you and I'm
gonna share with your seven habits that
can help you dominate in 2019 but I'm
not gonna sugarcoat anything I'm gonna
be very direct with you and what you do
with it it's completely on you the first
one is very specific to those of you
that change your mind very very often
it's a bad habit and it's costing you
relationships friendships and success in
business let me explain what I mean by
this no matter what business you choose
to do they're all ugly no business is
pretty it's like a relationship
there isn't anything you're gonna do in
the world of business that's gonna be
all good and dandy nothing not a single
business however this is a common trend
you see what a lot of people none of us
like to lose but some people when they
lose they respond in three different
ways one is fries they don't know what
to say the other one is they go and
fight and the last one is they flight
you know what flight is they change
their minds I don't want to do this
anymore and they run away you know why
because they're afraid of commitment
very simple in the world of business in
real world of business if you want to
win a 20-19 if you keep changing your
mind nobody is gonna take you seriously
the second one is for those of you that
like to win arguments with words let me
explain to what I mean by this you don't
understand how hard I'm working I am the
best you don't even know what's going on
let me explain to what happened I'm
doing my best I'm doing the most
appointments I'm working hard I'm
running appointments I'm running this
the best way to win arguments is to win
arguments with performance not with
words because when you win arguments
with performance everybody knows what
you did when you win arguments with
words it may be because you're a
wordsmith but maybe you're not a worker
to get the credibility of other people
who know what it is to work in 2019 win
arguments
with numbers with performance not just
words the third one this is one thing I
never liked coming up it was a lack of
maturity on my end and it was being
accountable and let me explain to what I
mean by accountability I'm not talking
about just accountability as in well go
be countable to somebody no no there's a
part about being accountable and then
there's a part about being accountable
to the right person let me explain the
difference anybody can be accountable to
somebody that's a lower performer
anybody can be accountable to somebody
that's not the same level as you hey
friend hold me accountable well we're
not gonna be that tough on ourselves but
there's a difference between you being
held accountable by somebody on a weekly
basis that is ahead of you who is
willing who is willing this is the key
not everybody is willing to deal with
everybody who is willing to hold you
accountable with your performance on a
weekly basis and it's not afraid of
pointing out and saying look at this
part look at that part look at this part
as a CEO of an insurance company that's
growing we had a board meeting today the
entire conversation with the board
meeting today where we invited every
single insurance carrier was we were
being held accountable non-stop the
entire time and you know what happens as
you want to build a bigger business
accountability must go higher the fourth
habit is directed to those of you that
are so determined to win that you look
at everybody in your life as somebody as
a piece on the chessboard this person
can help me do this and that person can
help me do this and this person is gonna
help me advance to the other area and
what happens when you look at everybody
like that that they're disposable
there's one thing that goes away the
value of relationships goes away I just
turned 40 years old and I can tell you
one thing at 40 that's different than 30
that's different than 20 is
relationships let me explain it maybe
from a different angle think about it
this way who are the five relationships
that you currently have in your life
business personal life five
relationships that you currently have
right now in your life that you cannot
lose and you want to have 10 20 30 40
years from now who are those five
relationships think about those names
write them down what are you doing to
water those relationships very similar
to water and good plant what are you
doing to watering those relationships to
make sure
they win just as much as you win so 10
20 30 years from now those relationships
are still in your life because the idea
of wanting to do something big in 2019
and kick-off the next 5 10 20 years as a
massive massive run of your life you're
not gonna be able to do it with a lot of
solid relationships so in 2019 start
valuing the right relationships like you
never have before
the fifth one is directed to those of
you that are always looking at people
and saying this person must change you
he must change you she must change here
but there's one person you never look at
and that's yourself so what's the
solution and 2019 make an effort to
study every single one of your trends
let me explain to you what I mean by
studying your trend the next time you're
angry get a paper and pen and write down
exactly what caused you to be angry if
you're depressed if you're agitated if
all of a sudden you're having a division
with somebody you've been very good for
four six twelve months why are you all
of a sudden angry at this person why are
you taking things out on this person
maybe you just spoke to your ex and
maybe your ex doesn't like this person
and every time you talk to your ex he
says well you know how he is you know
how she is and all of us and you're
taking it out on this person what
happened there study or trends and when
you get lazy study your trends and when
you get urgent when you work harder when
you're positive when you're happy when
you're fired
up when all of a sudden people want to
be around you when do people not want to
be around you what causes it
20-19 study yourself the way the best
hedge fund managers study stocks and
look how quickly you'll start changing
many of your bad habits with good ones
the sixth one is specifically directed
to all the Mamas boys out there yes all
the mama's boys those are the ones that
are about to turn this video often go to
a different place because your feelings
got hurting you said something like I
don't have to listen to your Patrick
well you're right you don't have to
listen to me but you're 20 or 19 can
also be the same as 20 18 not a good one
so if you want to have a better 20 19
you may want to listen to me for 60
seconds let me explain to you what I
mean by momma's boys' here's what
happens many time Mama's boys do thinks
to get unnecessary attention because
they were raised by their mom to
constantly get attention their father
and them had friction they would go to
their mom and mom would say it's okay
baby
you're amazing I love you you're so
perfect you're amazing you're beautiful
you're gorgeous and they're constantly
getting that attention that unnecessary
attention so you may be 34 years old and
you still want that kind of attention so
let's just say something doesn't go good
your way on any given day to everybody
around you you'll do whatever you can to
get unnecessary attention let me explain
to what ends up happening eventually
when you do that people runs you
eventually get burned out what happened
to constantly give you attention that
you need to be happy and eventually they
leave you know what the solution is 2019
remember how I said study your trends
the next time you're about to act up to
get unnecessary attention study that
trend and say I am NOT doing this
because every time I do this I'm going
back and being the eight-year-old that I
used to be and I'm no longer eight
I'm not 34 and last but not least in
2019 make a decision to create a new
habit every single time you're in any
environment whether you're the leader
you're part of a team and everyone's
asking you to come through for a number
don't just do what people expect you to
do over-deliver surprise everybody if
somebody tells you to do a million
dollars of sales in a year two million
three if somebody is expecting you to do
a hundred thousand dollars in a month do
170 don't just hit the numbers
everybody's expecting you do over
deliver at our board meeting today I
specifically told every single insurance
carrier that was there one of the
reputations we wanted to build from day
one is when we told you we were gonna
give you a certain amount of premium we
wanted to give you twice as much as that
premium as you thought we were gonna get
and eventually a reputation is built
build the reputation in 2019 of every
time a number comes out of your mouth
that you commit to you're gonna do even
more than that so for those of you that
are seriously committed about these
seven habits this is what I'm gonna do
for you how to a graphic design team put
together two images for you one is a
background for you to put on your phone
so every single time you pick up your
phone you can see these seven habits to
be reminded of them in 20
and second there's a score image if you
want to put it on social media or to put
it somewhere they can look at if you
print it around your office again to be
reminded of it click on a link below to
get those two images the background or
the one for your phone or the one as a
poster and if you are fully committed to
the habits that I just covered with you
send me a tweet at Patrick with David
and tell me Pat I'm committed in 2019
take everybody bye-bye